[Music]
happy Victory there let's get on with it
please
yes
ravishing that I mean the flowers are
rishy I just need to be brief for these
briefings Madam Chancellor Corporal
zubac not nice what they're calling you
butcher there's a good man in there who
deserves
love the chancellor has a bit of an
infatuation he not d dous is
[Music]
he she'll lose interest she always does
hot what if this time she doesn't I love
to smash their faces anyone who makes
you
weak Madam Chancellor let's keep the
gloves on this is not a confrontation
we're just saying what's
true this is emphatically not business
as usual the protest will only spread
red I want more you should have more
your people that're turning on you madam
sit down sit down piece of advice why
don't I just smash your face in well if
you think it'll help you will need to be
better at being normal when you're not
normal it makes me feel like you're
telling me that I'm not normal which
makes me distrust all of you and want
you to be dead so just be better at
being
normal anyone who dares insult
me or my country shall feel my
Fury Madam if you are indeed proposing
an
invasion no one is proposing an invasion
no
one call it an expression of peace and
love something like that something fun
Snappy yep
[Music]
good
now